after first finding american fame and
the goofy 90s sitcom two guys a girl in
a pizza place Ryan Reynolds moved on to
play leading roles in multiple romantic
comedies as well as action flicks like
blade Trinity Green Lantern and of
course Deadpool
the role he was born to play Reynolds
always brings a playful edge in a sharp
sense of humor to his roles which can
lead to a lot of extra footage and
hilarious outtakes here are some of Ryan
Reynolds best bloopers Deadpool with
Deadpool Hollywood finally figured out
what to do with Ryan Reynolds the
fictional character blended so
seamlessly with Reynolds real-life sense
of humor that the movie relied heavily
on Reynolds improvisation however only
one take of a scene can make the final
cut meaning there's a lot of Deadpool
outtake footage before Wade Wilson
becomes Deadpool he submits to some
highly questionable medical
experimentation he keeps his spirits up
by making fun of his captors which gives
Reynolds a chance to rattle off
different insults you're gonna leave me
all alone here with Henry Winkler you
know leave me all alone here with you
guys you're gonna leave me all alone
here with Criss Angel Mindfreak then
there's this scene where Deadpool shows
up at the x-men mansion and talks about
the joys of joining the team that's
right I can't wait it to join the gang
can't wait to pick a beast a nice little
belly rub it's gonna be great blade
Trinity what few comic moments there are
in the dark and violent conclusion -
Wesley Snipes Vampire Hunter trilogy
come courtesy of Ryan Reynolds even
though blade himself ignores most of
those jokes in this blooper director
David s Goyer let Reynolds riff and
character describing his characters
musical tastes in the process I mean
more of a Kenny G fan myself you know
early stuff though
before he sold out me more of a Clay
Aiken fan oops and the platen me more of
a Don Johnson fan people don't know he
recorded an album the proposal this 2009
rom-com started three of Hollywood's
most well-liked actors Sandra Bullock
Betty White and Ryan Reynolds one of the
scenes they all get together for a group
hug which leads to one of the best
bloopers from the movie she's got my
nipple honestly we can't tell if
Reynolds is making fun of Betty White's
height or if white actually tried to
take a bite out of him either way at
least they didn't start kissing nope
Reynolds saved all that loving for the
dog the hit man's bodyguard regardless
of your religion nuns are generally
regarded as people you don't mess with
so of course that's what Ryan Reynolds
does in one scene for the hit man's
bodyguard Reynolds is in applause with a
bunch of clapping nuns he waits for a
quiet moment and launches a clap attack
on the one sitting right next to him the
change-up in this blooper from the body
switch movie the change-up Reynolds
reacts quickly when he can't remember
his lines
he stays in character as long as he can
before admitting the co-star Jason
Bateman that he has no idea what he's
supposed to be doing
I don't feel particularly good about
this we're just doing a pickup no I just
had a complete brain malfunction
probably because I don't feel
particularly good about this
just friends let's face it poop jokes
can be pretty funny they're even funny
and repeat possibly even funnier case in
point this blooper from the comedy just
friends each time Reynolds tries to say
his ridiculous line he and co-star Amy
smart just laugh harder and harder leave
why would mr. peepee pants one
leaf stick around myself fad stick
around I'm gonna crap my pants
RIPD it's nice to know that some actors
never lose their sense of fun while
filming a movie as this footage from the
making of r.i.p V shows Reynolds always
has a blast while making a film of
course it helps that he's got some
fellow goofballs like Jeff Bridges and
Kevin Bacon to play against and a stunt
car to mess around in thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]